I need emergency assistance.
(Over radio) Whats your location?
Wind River Indian Reservation
I'm June Banner
FBI. Welcome to Wyoming.
By yourself?
It's just me.
That's Cory Lambert, he's the one who found the body.
This is a homocide.
I knew that girl. She was a fighter.
They gave six officers to cover an area the size of Rhode Island.
Maybe you can help.
Well I know what the tracks say.
What is it that you do again?
I hunt predators.
(gunshot)
So why don't you come hunt one for me then?
(cocks gun)
Why would a teenage girl be out will be out here? What was she running from?
You're looking for clues. But youre missing all the signs.
Shouldn't we wait for backup?
This isn't the land of backup Jane. This is the land of you're on your own.
Oh my God
You won't get the answers you're looking for. No matter what you find.
Why would your daughter run from home?
I don't know why, she didn't tell me.
Out here, you cannot blink, not ever.
This place, what it takes from us.
What it took from you.
I got lucky.
Luck, that lives in the city
Get your hand off that weapon.
Hey!
Jane!
Luck don't live out here.